if you want mine would you stay here
just for three
four nights until i leave to go back to
michigan
i will stick with you till you leave
from here
i appreciate you ron i i appreciate you
harris i appreciate you so much
wait wait wait wait stephanie what did
you say
i appreciate you ron i i appreciate you
ron
i appreciate you ron i i appreciate you
harris
she almost called harris ryan and they
continued all the conversation as if it
didn't happen
but hey it's an honest mistake if i
moved on that fast to a man's cousin
i would probably confuse their names too
just hours after stephanie called it
quits with ryan
she invited harris to the resort and now
he gets to enjoy
all the perks that come with being her
boy toy
i don't know i'll take you upstairs so
you can get a shower and freshen up
before we go to dinner and drinks okay
all right okay have your bag thank you
so i'm just gonna make the most of the
rest of my trip here in belize
what else can i do enjoy the trip by
yourself and not deal with these shady
men
stephanie has now gone as far as asking
harris if he would be open to living
with her in michigan
will gets his response in just a few
plus rebecca is starting to grow
suspicious of zied
after he suddenly tells her that they
need to get married before ramadan
which is in a few weeks so if you if i
don't marry you quickly
you go home yeah hmm
should she be concerned
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisa
i'm gonna be honest this week's episode
was a bit
slow but there are a couple moments that
we have to talk about
so let's go ahead and get into them
kicking things off with our dear friend
stephanie as she was preparing for
harris to arrive at the resort
she revealed that she's canceling ryan's
visa to america
she also said that she doesn't miss him
but based off of the way she said it
it's kind of hard to believe ryan was
someone i was gonna marry
i was gonna spend the rest of my life
with him but i miss my cat a hell of a
lot more than i miss ryan
i don't miss ryan i don't miss ryan
i mean who are you trying to convince
stephanie the cameras or
yourself huh obviously she is not trying
to sit with the feelings
that come with ending a three-year
relationship
so to numb the pain she got cute put on
her little lipstick purse
and shredded towards ryan's cousin
harris
para wow
middle of the night i get a call from
stephanie she told me she was
going through some problems and
difficulties with ryan so
right away next day get on the bus early
morning five o'clock
take about four hours to reach the city
jump on the boat
take aboard the next two hours to reach
the island and here i am
in a day's notice this man took time
away from his job
as a farmworker to come see stephanie
there are also some reports out there
that he has a family of his own
so i know you're not supposed to assume
people's motives but
this clearly looks like a money mission
for harris
traveling six hours they cannot be that
good of friends
ryan he's crossed the line and it's over
it's over for good this time
he is a master manipulator
that's why one of the main reasons i
told you stephanie you're going the
wrong way
from the first time i told stephanie
about it i thought stefanie
ran in the right guy for you man he's
terrible
well damn harris that was harsh i don't
know about you
but for me it's kind of sad to see these
two cousins
just trash each other on tv it makes me
wonder
what happened before stephanie that
turned them into such enemies
is it just jealousy or did something go
down
whatever it was at this point stephanie
is just a pawn in the game
who is well aware that she is causing an
even bigger divide between them
you don't deserve someone to come and
treat you the wrong way in life you need
someone to take care of you and be there
at your side
thank you you and i have always had a
connection
close coming too yes yes so if you want
mine would you stay
here just for three four nights until i
leave
to go back to michigan
i will stick with you till you leave
from here
i appreciate you ron i i appreciate you
harris
i appreciate you so much
i'm not gonna lie to you all talking
about stephanie's storyline at times
just
feels weird because it's so extreme
very extreme but
it does remind us that you have to be
mindful of who you confide in
because as we see here there are people
that will take advantage of your
weakness
and use it for their come up when
stephanie and ryan broke up a year ago
harris swooped in and slept with her now
stephanie called off her engagement to
ryan
and harris once again right there
waiting for his golden opportunity and
based off the preview for next week
it might be close i've always thought i
wonder what it would be like to have
paris in the united states with me i'm
already
over there with you stephanie going to
america
i think i can do a lot better i know
stephanie and the americans they are
rich people
wow at this point i don't even think
stephanie cares that she's being used
i don't think she cared she was being
used with ryan
which is unfortunate also
i know that harris has somewhat turned
into the villain
in this situation and although i don't
agree with his actions
at all it is clear that
he just wants a better life for himself
but he's chosen such a shady way to go
about it
alright enough of stephanie let's move
on to rebecca and zied
rebecca's been working hard and zied
he's been stuck in the apartment so she
took the day off to take him to this
beautiful location
where she hopes they can get married oh
rebecca surprised me about the horse
that smacked me
so happy i can't do him or no
yes sir his name is pendragon the horse
is so big and handsome
and the curves too that's amazing
did you take a picture i did
i love the smell of horses yeah you want
to go for a ride
yeah despite everything going on in the
world today
is all about getting zied excited for
planning the wedding
now everything was going fine until they
actually started talking about the
wedding
rebecca opened up about this fairy tale
experience she wants to have
taking this same carriage ride after
they say i do
and ziyad just shut down her excitement
by saying that he wants to get married
at the courthouse
which didn't have me concerned until i
started listening closely
to the rest of their conversation i mean
i understand the court
but i just want us to have a good
time a beautiful wedding yeah i
understand
but i mean for married quickly
i think no isolation only marry you
in the court i get that the coronavirus
is a new complication in our 90
day timeline but i'm just disappointed
that zied
is willing to settle so quickly to have
just a regular courthouse wedding
so the excuse here was the coronavirus
but once they got inside and continued
to talk about the wedding
the issue became ramadan which shocked
rebecca because he's never
brought this up before ramadan a holy
month for muslims
is in a few weeks and according to zead
they need to get married
before the holiday begins because he's
never heard of anyone getting married
during that month all right look
seriously i'm not gonna marry you
before ramadan that's not what i want
what won't me do
my visa finish after ramadan in one week
my visa finish if still the corona virus
problem
and everything close what i do is the
time
if not marry you before ramadan not in
one home
although they are not see you what
i got a ted or you go home where are you
gonna go
if you want this so wait you're telling
me that i can't sleep in my own home
unless i marry you before ramen yeah
yeah i'm just thinking
if she never brought him to this wedding
venue when was he gonna tell her this
i'm not sure if it's one of those
situations where he underestimated how
much
a wedding means to rebecca or if it's
just a lack of respect
the moment zied came to america he knew
when his visa was ending
and he knew when ramadan was starting
when you don't tell somebody
important information like that as soon
as you think of it
it comes off as if you're trying to be
sneaky
and rebecca loves yet i'm sure if he was
up front from the beginning
she would have no problem marrying him
before ramadan
but now she's triggered the last thing i
wanted to do was rush this wedding
the the 90 days for me are very
important
because the last time that i did this uh
with my ex for morocco
i married him really quickly and
he became an entirely different person
but between you know the coronavirus
and the ramadan deadline
i don't know what i'll do next week
things get more intense between rebecca
and zied
because she's not budging and he's not
either
i waited two years for you to get here
and then
because i won't marry you in two weeks
you want to go stay somewhere else yeah
for him to now say well you know what if
you don't marry me right now i'm gonna
go live somewhere else
makes me feel like telling him go live
somewhere else tell him rebecca
because he's acting as if you're the one
who just dropped this life-changing
information on his lap
the least he could do is look her in the
face all right 90 day fans fam
i was actually rooting for rebecca zied
so hopefully he's not up to something
and they can get this together
really quick but in the meantime to make
sure you stay updated on all the latest
news coming out the 90 day universe
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time